I'm joking Watson stow in East London by
the Labour MP Stella Creasy and from
Westminster by Kate Andrews author of
the gender pay gap reporting measures at
the Institute of Economic Affairs Stella
Creasy I'd like to begin with you you
know part of this campaign why did you
decide that you needed to start it well
because it's one thing to have the data
which now companies have to give us by
Wednesday of this week all companies
with over 250 employees both in the
public and the private sector have to
publish this data but if we just have
the data we don't do anything with it
then what's the point so we've set up
this campaign for two reasons first and
foremost because we've heard some
worrying reports of when people have
started talking about the data that has
been published being shut down in their
workplace being told that somehow they
raise these issues it might affect their
career so we want to be very clear that
people have a protected right to freedom
of speech in the workplace to raise
these issues to ask their employers what
they're doing about them to be part of a
trade union to be part of a women's
network saying this isn't good enough
and but also to gather people's
experiences of what happens when they
use this data so that we can then use
that in Parliament we want employers to
know that we have the back of those
people coming forward wanting to have
this debate and that we will act if we
see them being silenced ok Katie Andrews
hashtag pay me - are you going to be
signing up
I'm not when the me to campaign first
started it was about women all over the
world coming forward with their
experiences of harassment and sexual
assault it was very serious it was very
meaningful and it was organic
hashtag pay me - has taken the me to
campaign and it's brought it into an
area that is so deeply misleading I've
been on the website there's very limited
information but what it does essentially
is it masquerades as an Equal Pay
website equal pay is mandatory in the UK
by law men and women doing the same work
have to be paid the same but this
campaign is trying to conflate equal pay
with the gender pay gap the gender pay
gap comes down to a myriad of factors
from job to age to experience many of
which have absolutely nothing to do with
gender and it's trying to conflate the
two which I think at best is deeply
misleading and frankly to piggyback
the me to campaign with this kind of
misleading information is I mean the
only way to paint it is that it's
insulting Stella what do you say to that
deeply misleading in that you just
piggyback it right sorry okay Kate okay
Kate your problem is that a fan tag my
problem is that this data is showing us
that on average women are paid 14
percent less than men in the
organizations they work for in fact in
some organizations it's much bigger
we've got one example already of a
hospital where four where every 59p a
woman owns a man earns a pound that is a
gender pay gap that is absolutely right
it's something different for the equal
pay legislation that we have in this
country but we need to deal with both
because what this data is telling us is
that women are not being promoted not
being given the same opportunities and
as a result we're all missing out in
Skye for example only a third of the top
jobs are taken by women that's now what
this data tells us frankly getting hung
up on the hashtag rather than
recognizing what we're facing in this
country that doesn't sound like good
economics to me Kate I'm not hung up on
any hashtag I'm hung up on the fact that
these new pay gap measurements are
incredibly misleading and frankly
useless only one of the six measurements
has any real merit none of them break
down jobs age background experience time
taken off work you have not proven any
kind of gender pay gap what you have
done is push many many misleading
statistics into the public domain and it
is absolutely an attempt to box women in
to this victimhood mentality that when
you actually break down the data if you
look at the official data from the
Office for National Statistics does not
exist there is a reason that this new
data does not line up with the official
data and that is because it is so bad
being health-related if you're an
economist it doesn't matter which side
of the divisional trees such as bad day
today okay you've just missed quoted the
Office of National Statistics okay you
just go to the Office of National
Statistics which own studies show that
indeed the gender pay gap amongst young
women graduates and male graduates is
growing so actually equal pay and gender
pay and the most stellar data sensing
data that we have in front says well
well we can ask the international
concerns but
you can taste the garden spending five
point one one at a time yes just go one
at a time I'm sorry Stella yeah okay
Kate you want to talk about the data
that's been published I think a lot of
women right now who are looking at data
that shows that the bonuses that men in
their company are getting are sometimes
50 percent more than them would disagree
with you that is a meaningful
information to know I think a lot of
women in companies and indeed in our
public sector for example in the NHS
where we're seeing a pay differential
despite the majority the workforce being
female would find it insulting that you
think that that is an interesting thing
that we need to discuss we need to
understand why that is happening this
data is the first step the next step is
to ask companies what they're doing
about it that's exactly what this
research helps us to do and related to
say that this data is misleading or
unimportant well I have listened to UK
and I have listened to you insult the
Office of National Statistics and their
own research so I think today Stella at
the end I'm sorry I'm here I disagree
and I think the numbers of women it's
actually about helping everyone Kate
because because the gender baked app
doesn't help anyone what it also tells
us is that still too often the idea
about flexible work is something that
women have to deal with rather than
parents for example and what we're
looking at for these companies
thankfully most of them take a very
different view to you they recognize
it's a problem if they're not tapping
into the pool of talent they have in
their companies because of the gender
they know they're missing out what this
data is doing is driving that
conversation what this campaign is doing
is helping women and men be part of it
Stella the truth of the matter is that
when you actually examine the
measurements of this you need so much
more data in order to render anything
meaningful from them if you look at the
bonuses that you just mentioned it is
impossible to know if men and women are
being paid on fair leave via bonuses
unless you know what their actual
salaries are so you can know the
percentage of their salary that's going
towards a bonus and so you actually have
some meaningful data - we don't
sella the crude numbers that the
government has mandated that the
companies report does not dive into any
of this and that makes it extremely
misleading companies like easyJet in
phase eight are always going to have a
why gender pay gap not because of
discrimination but because they do mass
hiring of women and to their primary and
the majority of their roles
which happened to be in things like
retail and cabin crew you are
government's figures do not highlight
that in any capacity and now you have
launched a campaign that directly tries
to complete the gender pay gap of equal
pay and if I may just finish because I
think you have had your time to speak
what this real attempt is here is to hit
the reset button on equal pay women have
been doing so well and the stats prove
it when you eventually break down the
theater like four like that the the
victimhood groups need to hit the reset
button in order to keep their membership
going it works in elections
it works for things like the equal pay
day campaign but women out there and
here you know just how misleading this
data is and I don't think your hashtag
or your attempt to make companies report
as misleading figures is helping them
okay I'm dealing in facts and the
narratives that we have talked about the
different quarters I actually agree with
you I absolutely agree with you that
this dataset is not complete for example
I'd like to look also at the difference
in terms of people from black and ethnic
minority backgrounds from disability
backgrounds but I'm just worried Kate
the more and more I hear you talk and
bandy around terms like victimhood the
more and more I don't think you're
dealing in facts and actually what has
been recorded at the moment this data is
driving a conversation because it does
give four different pay quartiles in
companies that's how I know that
Kimberly right now is working for an
organization where only a third of the
people in the top jobs and the top pay
quartiles are women because that data is
in the data set hey I listen to you I've
listened to you and I've been insulted
by you you've insulted the owners at the
very least don't insult campaign you
know the victimhood to talk about gender
pay no to completely let's not talk
about who's insulting who here let's
talk about going forward so Kate where
do we go from here I think we absolutely
need to roll back these pay gap measures
because they haven't actually revealed
anything meaningful one area where I do
think Stella and I might have some
agreement is on things like shared
parental leave and it's a real shame
that more men haven't taken that up the
only way to really tell
go women getting into more senior roles
is for more men to take time off work
and to really split childcare I mean
that would be a much more interesting
campaign especially because we know that
so few men in the UK have taken up
shared parental leave but at the moment
what we're doing is we're demonizing
actually many quite well-meaning
companies and we're really insulting
women by suggested to them that they're
not doing as well as the actual official
date data shows and and when you break
down these job comparisons like for like
when you look at age when you look at
experience you get a very different
picture and it's really important that
women sitting at home hear that because
it's just not what they're being told by
MPs by representatives and by a
modern-day feminist movement that
doesn't have their best interest at
heart okay Stella Creasy where do you
think we should go from here
yeah and back back in the real world
where women do recognize in their
workplaces they still face
discrimination where this data is
helping to drive the conversation about
what happens next maybe one of the
things that we need to do is to tackle
those tired old gender stereotypes that
somehow suggest that retail is for women
or that companies like easyJet where
there are pilots that women can't fly
planes may be one of the things that we
actually need to do is ask employers why
their top jobs aren't open to women
which is what this data will help us
start that conversation to do it's also
about making sure this conversation
isn't shut down by people talking about
victimhood
or somehow that modern feminism is
failing women feminism isn't about women
it's about power it's about the power to
see that 51% of our community doesn't
get the same chance as the other 49%
because of their gender this data is
part of that conversation it's not the
only conversation I know from actually
working in the communities and working
in the real world that's a conversation
we need to have lots of us talk to
Stella Creasy Kate Andrews thank you so
much for coming on and chatted to us